No, no, no, no-
(screams) NO!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Slender Adrift.
Now, this is a throwback. Not that this game is old-
-but I haven't played a Slender game in years.
And just recently I played SCP Containment Breach and it kinda got me thinking-
-about the old horror games, and I saw that this game, was fairly recent,
And reminiscent of the original forest in Slender, so I'm gonna give it a go if I have-
Do I have a mouse here? I don't think I do.
Oh! Collect all 5 pages.So, in the advent of the original Slender games,
This one looks a little janky
Oh my god- is that the original building?
I don't know if they tried to emulate what-
Oh my god! It's the original building! But updated in HD!
Ooh, and by HD I mean heavily dicked, because this place doesn't look good at all.
"Leave me alone." You know, you'd think I'd learn that after all these years that Slender just wants to be left alone-
-and doesn't actually wanna be messed with.
So I'm gonna skedaddle on- Why is-? Why's there electricity running through the floor here?
And also Mr.- HEY! FUCKING WHAT- AND WHY!? (jumpscare warning)
And also how- what is tHAT-!
Oh! Oh, I can hear him stimpy-stomping all over the woods!
Well that's not good for me! What the fuck!?
Alright-y then, let's try that again.
So, getting the pages is a bit of a goof.
Now that seemed- that seemed a lot worse than it has been in the past. Is it still gonna be ran-dom-ly gener-ah-ted?
Oh, there it is. Hello.
Alright, I got one. As long as Slender doesn't come a'dickin', we're gonna be fine.
Ah, fuck! Eh fuck! Oy fuck! OY! OY! OY! OY! HEY!
ZIGGY-ZAGGY-ZIGGY-ZAGGY! OYOYOY!
Get away! Ooh, I can hear 'im, oh Jesus, that's disconcerting.
Well how am I gonna get away from that?
Where is he? Wh- Ahh! Ahh- Where is he? I don't know where he is!
Where is he?
Okay, alright that's weird. That's a different mechanic than it was before. So I gotta keep my eyes on you!
Oh, where am I? This another building? Or is it the SAME building? Or is that a wall!? Ahh! I've mistaken a building for a wall-
-cuz I'm an idiot! Well let's keep stepping across it!
I don't know where the hell I am or be, but I be lost and am fucked!
So I guess I know exactly where I am and be! Where are you?
Where? Where? I don't see you, which is good and also bad.
Wh-What am I-? Am I stuck on something- I'm stuck on a wall! Again! I'm dumb, 'cuz I don't know where I am!
Except in the zone of being- fffubberknucked!
Ahh! Nononononononono- nuh- nuh- neh. NEH! NEH!! NEH!! NEAH! NEACK! NEAAAAACK!
I gotta try to find something to be- whoa, wait, whoa, am I up on a path? How did I get up on a path?
I can't see dick! I mean, it wouldn't be good to see dick in this woods either but I mean-
I seem to be making a lot of dick references- I'm gonna go down here. Hopefully find something in the channel.
Goddamnit, how am I gonna find another goddamn page? I can't see in front of my goddamn face.
Ooh, hello. Well, the geometry seems to be a little broken here.
I theem to be sthuck.
Maybe if I just- wait can I jump over the walls here? FREEDOM! FREEDOM, FUCK YOU MAN! HAHAA!
I've beaten your sys- aw, fuck. Well, shitty dicks. I don't think I was supposed to come here.
Ooh- Hey. Heyheyheyheyhey! AYE-AYE-AYE-AYE-AYE-AYE!
AYE AYE AYE AYE AYE! GO FUCK! YOURSELF! AND GO DIE! Oh god-
Where am I? Am I back at the building that I was juUUust at- HEY! OHH, FUCK, I SAW HIM!
HeEEeY! Hey! HEEY! You're really aggressive today!
Being the day that it's been three years since the last time I saw you. So how 'bout you stop?
Huh? You good with that? Good. Me too.
Hey, just- where are you? Is this a tunnel? What am I looking at? No, it's just my flashlight ring- HEY!
OOHH FUCK. I thought I saw tentacles. --aaahheehhaaaaaaeeeeiiiiihhh- YEI-EE-YEI-EE-YEI!
Okay. We're fine.
We're not fine! AYE-YEI-YEI-YEI- God, what the- LOT OF TREES! That's a prison of trees!
Fuck, I don't know where any other page would be! There's only four other pages but I'm completely frickin' lost!
Man, and then this map isn't exactly that big so how could I do this!?
Gotta stumble across one eventually. Where's the landmarks? Where's the giant red dildo? Come on! Dil-do or Dil-don't!
Oh my god. Oh, wh- Ey! I found another one! Is he gonna get more aggressive?Good. He should. Hey, a rock!
Aw, man, my ancestors used to ride these bad boys around for miles!
That's weird.
Is that blood on the rock? Greeaat. There's no page on that rock? Greeaat. Do I see him? Is that a light?
Wow- HEY-! WHY? WHY!? WHY!? WHERE IS HE!? IS HE IN FRONT OF ME!? IS HE BEHIND ME? WHERE AM I!?
It's a goddamn truck.Is there something on the truck? Eeaaahh-FUCKYOUFUCKYOUFUCKYOUFUCKYOU!
I'm just checkin' the truck, man, just checkin' thetruck. Just checkin the- TheEere's nothing on the truck!
Where are you? Whoa, I don't like that. Okay, so I found a landmark but what does that mean?
Euhh, euuh. Where you at- WHERE YOU AT!? HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! STRANGER DANGER STRANGER DANGER STRANGER DANGER!
STRANGER DANGER! Stop that! Stop! Stop! STOP!
Hey, look, it's light here! Why is it light here? I dunno why it's light here! Is there ano- another page?
Where did these goddamn lights come from- stooOOOooOP IT!
Don't you dare. Don't you flip-dickin-dare! Don't you dare! Don't you dare on me!
OooOOooh I'm gon' get you!
Okay. NO! NONONO, THAT WAS TOO CLOSE- YOU GET STUCK ON THAT LAMP POST!  Hey, this is a big tree- Is there something on this tree?
Hangon, hangon- Oh there's a page! Okay, I got three of five ya bitch! HeEey, whoo, yea, he's gettin' real spooky now!
The spook levels have been cranked up to 11! HEY!
Stop it, stoop it, stooop, sti-stop- stOOoOP! STAaaRE- StorlAAaP-
Ah. So these are the walls, but there was- there was- EEAH! Four of five!
I just need one more. So there's gotta be something on either the truck, or the fuckin' other thing. The rock. This rock.
This big-ass rock- AY! AYY! AY! I'M ALMOST DONE WITH THIS!
I never beat the first game, so- be really cool if you let me beat this one.
Don't do it. Don't fuckin' do it- There you are. Nothing on the rock. . . They got nothing on the rock.
Fuck, where are you? Where are- HEY! HEY! HEY! HEY! WHERE ARE YOU!? WHERE ARE YOU!? I C- I- I HAVE NO IDEA WHERE YOU ARE.
WHERE ARE YOU!? WHERE IS HE!? OH, FUCK, THERE HE IS. Okay. Alright then.
That is fuckin' impossible 'cuz you have no- AH, FUCK! NO! NO! NO! NO! (jumpscare warning)
(SCREAMS)
Fffffuuck, maan! (voice crack)
I got trapped in a goddamn hole. Aaah, fuck!
Hello. Aha- whoa! Whoa, I found a weird one in the middle of nowhere. If I can find that truck, I think that'll be the last one. Okay.
Oh, what the fuck is this?
Hello. Hi, you have a page?
You have a page, you weird tunnel bastard? Where are you? There you are, okay, you stay right there buddy.
Okay, so there's gotta be- The truck has gotta be somewhere- Ooh! There it is! Please, please- come on!
You dickhole! Where could it be? It's gotta be on one of these things.
Right? Right?
AHH-! Oh, fuck. Goddamnit! Four of five agaaaain! I found like, four other landmarks but no pages on em'.
Unless I was just an idiot and didnt see it.
Fucking fuck! Okay, I dunno, I can't find the last page, I was wandering there for about 20 minutes straight.
I saw every landmark, I triple-checked everything, I dunno. I dunno where the fuck that last page was, so, I'm gonna leave it at that.
It's really interesting to be back in Slender, and I know in the original Slender, I actually never beat that game either.
But, y'know, it's just kind of nice to revisit the oold creepypastas and the old horror games,
I'm kinda being true to my own, 2013 self, so thank everybody so much for watching, if you wanna see this game for yourself I'll put a link in the description below-
And maybe you can find that last, elusive page.
So thanks again everyone for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video. Bye-byyyee!
(Outro Song) - Haunted  by Shirk